If we try to fold any of the curves on this graph across the y-axis,
none of them are going to map over to themselves.
So, they must not have symmetry across the y-axis.
The same is true of the x-axis when we try it there.
Folding them in half along this line is not going to make points up here match points down here,
because they're on opposite sides of the y-axis.
So, it looks like neither of these 2 symmetries applies in the case of odd functions.
However, let's look at these last 2 choices.
Maybe one of them works.
We know that this is a property of even functions, that points equidistant from the y-axis have the same y value.
But it doesn't look like this is true of odd functions.
If I pick some x coordinate like 5,
and I find the given y coordinate,
then finding the opposite x coordinate,
negative 5 does not give me the same y coordinate.
It's all the way down here, instead of up here.
However, these y coordinates are related.
This one is the negative version of this one.
So that means this last rule is true.